Revisiting painful memories…
In the home that she shares with her sister
and niece, Asifa Parveen looks at photos of
her wedding four years ago.
Her family had to pay a hefty dowry - but
her in-laws and husband didn’t think it
was enough.
They harassed and abused Asifa.
Finally, her husband Kamran Ali uttered the
word “talaq” or divorce three times over the phone,
ending their marriage of over
a year in the space of a few seconds.
Asifa Parveen, who was pregnant at the time,
turned to the police but they couldn't do much.
Muslim marriages are usually not registered.
And there is no law banning instant divorce.
“I was shell shocked.
I thought what’s going to happen to me?…My
life is in limbo.
I don’t know where I’m supposed to stay,
what I’m supposed to do, what will happen
to my daughter?”
It’s a situation that Niyazmeen is all too
familiar with.
The 29-year-old works in a slum in south Delhi.
She wants to raise awareness about the practice
of verbal divorce among Muslims and mobilize women.
Today she meets this group.
Most women here are poor, uneducated and were married off young.
Salma Begum is 22.
She suffered years of torture by her in-laws
- ending up in hospital with serious injuries
and almost completely losing her eyesight.
A few months ago, her husband divorced her
- over the phone - and took the younger of
Salma’s two children with him.
“My husband said I can’t see anymore,
I can’t walk properly.
I even need help to go to the bathroom.
That’s why he divorced me.
He doesn’t want me any more.”
Niyazmeen says widespread illiteracy and the
stranglehold of patriarchy leaves women highly
vulnerable when they are abandoned.
“Women have absolutely no rights, they are
left with nothing.
A man just says talaq or divorce three times
and walks away.
Just like that.
He’s free of all responsibility.
He just uses a woman and then dumps her.
He doesn’t pay any maintenance towards his
own children.
This is a huge problem in the Muslim community.”
The issue has triggered intense debate in
India.
The country’s top court is reviewing the
matter - amid growing calls to ban the practice.
But not everyone agrees.
The mid-17th century Fatehpuri Mosque is a
famous landmark in Old Delhi.
The imam of the mosque, Mufti Mukarram Ahmad
says triple talaq is an issue of faith and
personal law - and cannot be tampered with.
“There should be no change in our Muslim
personal law which is Sharia.
This is God’s law.
It’s based on the Koran and on the Prophet’s
sayings…
Women know very well that in the Sharia if there’s a marriage there could well be a divorce.
If you don’t like it, why get married in
the first place?
There should be no outside interference in
our faith.”
But that doesn’t fly anymore with women
like Asifa Parveen.
She wants a ban on triple talaq - and a tough
penalty for offenders.
So that her daughter is spared a similar ordeal
when she grows up.